SDL history professor whose latest book
is on tyranny 20 lessons from the 20th
century Timothy Snyder how you know
inserting fricassee great to see you
alright so you are your expert is an
expertise isn't tyranny so this is your
busy season uh yes and you offer 20
lessons but this is TV give us the top
three okay let me give you three in a
bonus the first is don't obey in advance
it's normal to adjust to in your
situation don't obey in advance
alright the dictator don't obey the
shift don't obey the drift don't follow
whatever else is doing when there's a
special moment like the present one
figure out what you stand for and be
yourself normally normally we adjust
like I may have not read this book yeah
I'm worried about the confusion can we
not show that one could we show the
other one it cares about tyranny and
books eh yeah that's what I love about
that brocade number to defend
institutions right this is this is not
this is a time when people like you and
me and my friends say the institutions
are going to save us this is wrong right
we have to save the institutions they
don't do
it's this this is this is the moment of
asked not what the institutions can do
for me it's ask what you can do for the
institution's fill them out support them
don't expect them to be robots because
they're not number three believe in
truth believe in truth without truth we
don't have trust without trust we don't
have the rule of law without the rule of
law we don't have democracy so people
who are going for post fact people who
are against the truth they're taking the
direct line to killing democracy it's
the shortcut to getting rid of democracy
when we when we think about building we
think about post fact when you think
about post fact we think post modernism
then we think Berkeley and baguettes and
France and nice things but what we
should be thinking about in all
seriousness is fascism
it's the fascists who said every day
light doesn't matter details don't
matter facts don't matter all that
matters is the message the leader the
myth the totality we should be thinking
about the 1920s right I mean if you I
made a little list of things about
Donald Trump which you know remind me of
third-world dictators
you're a narcissist who likes putting
his names on his name on buildings
that's what they do and yeah you appoint
your family members to positions of
power the your rallies are scary you
hate the press and use your own
propaganda outlet instead Lou you want
to hold missile parade it's you know if
you wanted to have a missile parade but
use your office for your own personal
financial gain you like other dictators
and strongmen you claim minorities are
the cause of the economic anxieties of
the majority you lie so so freely your
supporters give up it's everyone except
dressing in a military costume when is
that coming jock yeah
right so we I mean I'm not gonna laugh
at is that just funny I'm not gonna
laugh at any of that because you can
roll this third-world dictators in my
world where I come from it's it's the
1930s right
picking out a group of your neighbors
and citizens and associating them with a
worldwide threat that's that's the 1930s
right right and what we have to remember
about the 1930s we think of Hitler in
stallin is supervillains but they're not
they could only come to power with some
form of consent so what man was elected
right what exactly so this is the way
regime change normally happens there's
an election by the rules more or less
we'll talk more about that later and
after the election from within the
regime has changed step by step which by
the way is the bonus lesson the thing
that I really worry about is a lesson
towards the end of the book is the
Reichstag fire that moment when a leader
tell them what it right okay so I'll
tell you the so the my know tell them
alright so if you insist and Hitler gets
elected in 1933 elected right so you're
elected you don't necessarily have
policies that are popular after the
election there's a mysterious terrorist
attack you use that as the occasion to
Hitler's burn riot lers right Handelman
burned down the Reichstag which was
their Parliament we don't know who but
they blamed it on the Mexicans well no
he was it was it was it was the Muslims
but the point is when the serious point
is when terrorist attack comes you will
not necessarily know who did it but what
you can know is that certain kinds of
leaders will use that moment to society
your rights so when that moment comes
despite your fear and your grief during
your fear and your grief you have to
mobilize and protest for your own rights
because the Reichstag fire is the old
Marion book we cannot let that trick be
played okay I'm good